So how did we get this answer? Now, the pattern here
shows that it's most likely autosomal and not sex-linked or maternal,
because we see an even number of males and females affected
here, only 1 to 1. We don't see only males or
only females. And it can't be maternal because if we have
an affected child, they should all be affected and the mother
would also be affected. So this is most likely an autosomal
inheritance pattern. And it's most likely
recessive, because the trait skips generations.
And unaffected parents give rise to affected offspring.
If it were dominant, it would be the other
way around where we would have affected parents,
with affected offspring, and the trait not skipping generations.